what's going on guys this is rob and
with she-hulk coming out a lot of you
all had asked me to make a video
explaining frog man and to be honest i
think he's gonna be the standout star of
the she-hulk show to be quite frank with
you guys if they do him accurately like
he is in the comics because in the
comics frogman is amazing
i love his character or at least he was
more recently he had kind of a return to
the classic frogman which was awesome
but here's the thing there's two
variations of the character and the
funny thing about this is the origin for
eugene who's the one that we'll be
talking about here kind of gives us a
little bit of an origin for his father
vincent which is actually sort of
explained a little bit earlier so the
way this worked is that uh frogman first
appeared in marvel team-up issue number
121 in 1982 and he was created by jmd
matthias now what's funny about this is
that by and large the appearances of
frogman are going to be almost
exclusively confined to jmd matteo's
stories there are other people who
invoke him but like 80 to 90 of his
appearances are in matthias stories
which is kind of funny here but the way
this works in marvel team-up and this is
one of the things to know back in the
day marvel team up was a very
long-running comic and it was a very
very popular comic in its time and you
saw it play a few different roles you
saw team up stories which of course
followed the namesake so you'd see ben
graham and different things along those
lines but it was usually characters who
were like teaming up in stories that you
wouldn't normally see them team up in
and then in turn it was just kind of a
fun way to introduce other characters as
well and so the introduction of a
frogman comes by way of his father
vincent who basically hates superheroes
at the outset we're not really given a
definitive explanation as to why but
what we get in the story itself is just
some instance whereby he came into
conflict with daredevil now the reality
of this is that this story was told in
daredevil issue number 25 which came
before eugene's appearance in marvel
team-up and the way this worked is that
eugene's father vincent was why all
standards of measurement a loser is
basically what he was and he simply
wanted to prove that he could be
somebody and so ultimately he ended up
fashioning a costume for himself that
had springs in the feet started calling
himself leapfrog and then went on a life
of crime he ended up being defeated by
daredevil and then he was thrown in jail
and his wife rosie didn't make enough
money to keep them financially stable
until she died of cancer and so at the
moment what you have is vincent who's
basically haunted by the mistakes of his
past and of course time lost with his
wife who ended up passing away and he's
the one there to raise his son eugene
and so after hearing this story what
eugene ends up doing is actually donning
the costume in order to basically
restore his father's honor and make up
for his past disgrace and then starts
calling himself the fabulous frogman now
this was really really kind of a cool
thing because at the outset because it
was a marvel team-up story it was
spider-man teaming up with johnny storm
the human torch and so what you ended up
having was basically a kind of a few
handful of criminals that robbed a bank
they were ultimately defeated but the
spider-man villain speed demon returned
and then took off with the money and so
what this did is it led to a team-up
between spider-man and the human torch
to try to defeat speed demon but when
when when eugene jumped in as leapfrog
and then basically bundled his way
through the story he actually ended up
aiding in defeating speed demon and so
it was one of those things where he sort
of established himself even if only by
accident that while he wasn't a high
level superhero he wasn't an avenger or
anything like that the guy could do some
good but one of the cornerstones of his
character in these early stories is that
he would literally just happen to
succeed but he would he had no idea what
he was doing and he would often times
screw things up more than he got things
right this was built on in kind of uh
kind of a return and marvel team up
issue number 131 in 1983 with jmd
matthias which was actually the second
part of eugene's story that initially
kicked off in marvel team up 121. and
the cool thing about this and the way
this worked is that you basically picked
up with a villain by the name of white
rabbit who is basically a villain s
right a female villain that was largely
modeled after the white rabbit from
alice in wonderland and so ultimately
everything just kind of you know she's
going on a criminal spree and all that
kind of stuff and what ends up happening
is that joe face who was at one point a
criminal ally to vincent the father of
eugene basically brings him back into
the criminal fold by having him work on
uh on on the team of white rabbit and it
gets a little funny because there is a
point where like spider-man shows up and
all that kind of stuff and white rabbits
like let's all get out there and kill
them and the response of like vincent is
look i mean i'm all down for like robin
some banks and stuff but i don't know if
i'm down for like murdering folks you
know and he's like why are we even gonna
do that and she's like because it's fun
you know and so ultimately of course
he's basically saved and the day is
saved by eugene alongside spider-man and
then you end up finding out that the way
white rabbit was essentially arrested is
that following the attempt of joe face
to get vincent back into the criminal
life that vincent had actually turned
informant for the cops and he basically
was wearing a wire so everything that
white rabbit had said in front of him
was recorded handed over to the cops and
that's how she ended up getting busted
the significance behind this was that it
was vincent who was actually inspired by
eugene's superhero antics to try to
change his ways and to actually sort of
make up for his past misdeeds and so
what was really cool about this is that
you jumped to amazing spider-man number
247 in 1983 which was written by roger
stern now this is one of those instances
where jmd matthias had kind of kicked
off frogman he introduced him as a kid
who was really really trying and that's
one of the things you loved about his
character back in the day he was
basically a kid that you just kind of
had to root for he would screw up again
more often than he would do things right
but you just wanted to see him succeed
and so this is one of those instances
where he would just kind of get in the
way he didn't appear in the story very
long and in fact that would be an
on-running theme for his character that
really ran all the way up until 1987
when he effectively disappeared out of
comics for a handful of years and then
came back shortly after but at this
point it was one of those instances when
like he idolized spider-man and so he
would simply just appear in a story and
he would usually screw something up
spider-man would chastise him and then
send him home and that was basically it
and so in this particular instance in
amazing spider-man 247 that you actually
had spider-man who was hot on the heels
and it caught up to a handful of
criminals that it basically had these
plans and so on and so forth in the
midst of spider-man's attempt to deal
with them literally eugene flies in from
a skylight and is just like surprise
[ __ ] nobody suspects the fabulous
frog man and ends up screwing everything
up
and in fact because of the antics
because he actually knocks spider-man
into a pile of tires that basically it
allows the criminals to grab their plans
and leave and so of course eugene just
gets screamed at by spider-man who ends
up taking off now at that point again
this is one of the things behind the
stories he would just kind of appear off
and on in little moments and so the
following year in the new defenders
issue number 131 which i call the new
defenders it was the continuation of the
original defender's comic albeit the
roster had shifted up at this point but
it was in 1984 and again written by jmd
mathias and eugene actually tried to
join the team and this was again kind of
a humorous and a funny moment because at
the time beast who was sort of sharing a
role where he was one part x-men one
part avengers one part defenders he was
kind of playing that role of wolverine
where he was like on all the teams long
before wolverine did that but you had
beast who was actually making a speech
and then a villain named walrus showed
up out of nowhere who tried to attack
beast at that conference and then of
course eugene helps the defenders to
defeat walrus and then tries to join the
team now the on running theme behind
this is that the defenders are kind of
like no man like i mean because the the
rumors and really the stories about
frogman are essentially circulating
around the superhero community
spider-man ends up getting the most
grief out of everybody right he's the
one whose day kind of ends up getting
ruined by frog man more than anybody
else but the antics of frogman have
circled around enough to where nobody
really wants to have him on the team and
that's kind of the sad thing behind it
because again like you're just kind of
like he tries so hard he tries so hard
and i want to see him succeed but you
know he would bungle everything up
if you were on the defenders or any of
those teams and even the defenders are
like no we'd be a laughingstock if we
let this guy on the team that's not
going to happen but fortunately for them
they are spared
the heartache of having to break it to
eugene that he's just not good enough to
be on the team when eugene's dad shows
up and then chastises him and that was
one of the undercurrents that was going
on with eugene in the early days of his
appearances is that despite the fact
that he had donned the suit and
basically helped to defeat speed demon
in his early appearances and his dad was
proud of him for that the reality here
is that his father would often chastise
him for going out in the superhero
antics now it wasn't because his father
hated him being a hero if anything and
it really wasn't well shown by his dad
it was more based on the idea that his
father was afraid something would happen
to him not only that it was really
eugene just kind of going out there and
doing things and usually causing
problems and so it was one of those
situations where his father was also
concerned that because of what eugene
was doing that he would actually make a
negative reputation for himself as
opposed to a positive one and everybody
would avoid him going into amazing
spider-man issue 266 in 1985 this was
written by peter david and this was a
really really cool story because what
you end up having here is the formation
of what was called the misfits which was
the greatest team we never got to see i
love god i always loved the idea behind
it and i really wish we'd gotten the
stories of the misfits we never got them
and it would have just like like
literally well okay so the way this
plays out
[Laughter]
the way this goes down is you ended up
having toad from the brotherhood of evil
mutants who is basically trying to kill
himself by jumping off a building now
toad is a character who had been around
for quite some time uh he was always
kind of a lackey to be honest right i
mean the depiction of hammond like the
old fox x-men movies actually did him
more justice than how he was in the
comics he was okay but the reality is he
was originally part of the brotherhood
of evil mutants but he was never really
a guy you could take seriously and in
fact there came a point when he had left
the brotherhood and it struck out on his
own but it still continued to fail in
his various schemes and so what this did
is it led to him trying to simply just
off himself due to his failures as part
of the brotherhood and also going solo
but he was ultimately saved by
spider-man who actually offered toad his
friendship and so this turned into a
situation where toad kind of became that
socially awkward guy that just can't
recognize social cues the funny thing
here is that there comes a point when
because toad is basically spending time
with spider-man albeit spider-man
constantly trying to reject him because
he's like we're not partners this ends
up making the news and the news actually
broadcasts it from the direction of
saying toad is the new partner of
spider-man now of course this pisses off
eugene because from eugene's perspective
he was always rejected by peter parker
right peter parker's stance was always
like hey man i mean you're cool
sometimes i guess but like we're not
partners and so as a result of this
frogman or eugene actually picks a fight
with toad spider-man intervenes and then
simply tells them they should form their
own team that's just called the misfits
in order to just kind of allow
spider-man to get rid of eugene and toad
kind of push them both out of the way
and we never got the stories of the
misfits marvel if you see this give us
stories about the misfits right just do
it like as a retcon right like way back
in the day these are the stories of
misfits but instead the next time we
ended up seeing frogman actually came in
marvel fanfare issues 31 and 32 in 1987
which again was written by jmd matthias
now marvel fanfare was kind of one of
the unsung heroes of marvel comics to be
honest in terms of a publishing side it
was a team-up book but it was also more
of an anthology book the difference
between something like marvel fanfare
and marvel premiere or marvel presents
or journey into mystery or tales to
astonish or whatever is that marvel
fanfare was actually an anthology book
designed to showcase the very best
talent that marvel had at the time so if
you were a writer or an artist and you
were approached by al milgram who was
the editor at the time and in fact he
edited the series for the whole 10-year
run uh if you were approached by him and
it was hey would you like to have a hand
in crafting a story in marvel fanfare it
meant that you were you were very very
high on the talent list or you were
rising talent that was getting noticed
by the right people and so marvel
fanfare had a pretty solid following and
it had some great stories as you would
expect from some of the best writers and
artists from marvel coming at the time
and so what you ended up getting in this
marvel fanfare story which actually
stretched over issues 31 and 32 back in
87 is you actually had frog man meeting
captain america for the very first time
now again much like his encounter with
uh spider-man steve rogers didn't want
to partner with frogman because he knew
about his stories
he'd heard from peter parker that hey
man like this guy just kind of screws
things up and so what had happened is
that that frogman actually started
investigating essentially what seemed
like a murder and then told everybody
that him and steve were partners anyway
and so eugene's investigation actually
leads him to the layer of yellow claw
who if we're being honest with ourself
he was basically just a racist ass
caricature from back in the day he
literally was like he was just the evil
asian bad guy he was that caricature
that just simply hadn't gone away by
that point now before a lot of you guys
who love to be angry start getting you
know start freaking out over this he's
long since gone right so you know you're
gonna be getting pissed off about
something that came to an end years and
years and years ago but of course the
concern of of steve rogers once he
learns that eugene has been telling
everybody their partners and that he's
investigating a murder is that he's
going to end up in over his head which
is kind of the consistent story of
eugene in marvel comics and so of course
captain america tracks down eugene ends
up being ends up at the layer of yellow
claw and is also ensnared and so with
the two of them being captured eugene
having been the cause of it all that of
course this leads to spider-man
encountering vincent the father of
eugene who's aware of what eugene was
doing and then tells spider-man what's
going on because his concern is that
eugene's in over his head spider-man
figures out what's happening pretty fast
and of course assembles a full
contingent of the defenders and they of
course rescue captain america and eugene
after which eugene has yelled at for a
little while and then that's basically
it but following this and this is really
one of the more disappointing things
about his character following this there
wasn't a whole lot doing about his
character right in spectacular
spider-man issues 184 and 185 which
again were also written by jmd matthias
he appeared again didn't really have
much of a much of an event here he
appeared in a handful of stories
following that there was one point
during punisher war journal when he was
basically brought in and he was
essentially one of the people who were
almost animal in nature they were being
hunted by craven the hunter as almost a
sort of blend between legitimately
hunting animals and the story of the
most dangerous game it was just one of
these instances when he just kind of
bounced around here and there and never
really had any major significant moments
in marvel comics he did appear in events
like uh like avengers the initiative
those of you guys who were unfamiliar
with that the initiative was an actual
publishing line by marvel comics that
was based off the events of civil war
that the entire gist and the entire
ideology behind civil war as most of you
guys know was basically a war fought
between the various superheroes on
whether or not they should have to
register with the federal government
that in the end the bad guys won right
iron man and reed richards and hank pym
and those guys ended up coming out on
top iron man became director of shield
and hank pym and reed richards were able
to launch the 50-state initiative which
was essentially a government-sanctioned
superhero team each of which would exist
in the various 50 states that frogman
was a part of that that you also saw him
appearing in small things like secret
invasion where it turned out he was a
scroll and so on and so forth but this
notion of his early appearances back in
the 80s being very comedic stories
instances where he would just appear and
usually screw things up that it just
never really seemed to quite come back
again and even more recently in
christopher cantwell's run of iron man
during the books of korvac that while
that story which of course we did cover
that story focused heavily on michael
korvac basically returning and then
trying to acquire the power cosmic of
galactus yet again which both he and
iron man succeeded in doing which is you
heard that right iron man basically
became god i'll link the playlist down
in the description i'll link the iron
man playlist so you can watch all the
iron man videos it was a phenomenal
story but basically what you had here is
tony stark assembling a team that would
go under the radar of michael korvac the
reason being because if he assembled the
avengers or if he had reassembled force
works or any number of teams that were
in some form or fashion high profile it
would have drawn the attention of
quarterback the desire was to race to
the ship of galactus and essentially
seized the power cosmic before michael
korvac did such as it was both iron man
and quarterback accessed the power
cosmic seemingly at the same time and
their stories kind of went forward from
there but for frog man what was so funny
about this is that in order to assemble
a team that would simply fly under the
radar iron man basically grabbed a whole
bunch of street level and like z-list
characters so one of those of course was
frogman and of course the team was
basically christened the space friends
which i love i love that name the space
friends was such a great name for that
team
the funny thing about this is that when
frogman was initially approached by iron
man to join the team it was one of those
things where he was like finally i get
to team up with like a serious superhero
and i get to go on like a real adventure
and he did and it was amazing it was a
fantastic story you guys are welcome to
check it out if you guys want to see
what it was about but outside of that
again when it comes to frogman he had a
really really interesting run in the
early days but once jmd matteus had sort
of moved away from marvel comics that
you basically saw other riders kind of
throwing him in there here and there
roger stern people like that they were
kind of throwing him in and then that
was basically it right he would just
sort of appear his his comedic nature
was sort of gone he would have these
small little moments and so on but there
really wasn't a whole lot doing there
instead his real real kind of return to
form has sort of come during christopher
cantwell's run but we don't know how
much longer that's going to go so at the
end of the day that really is all who
frogman is he's a kid that just wanted
to become a superhero so he stole his
dad's villain costume and then basically
bungled everything up but you can't help
but cheer for him because his heart is
in the right place with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end thank you all for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace
[Music]